everyone was really nice to me you know  the but it did feel very lonely  sometimes because um you know tom's  awesome but he's a pretty private person  and we developed a really sweet sort of  like brother-sister relationship  um maybe because he felt bad for me but  um  we also both like we're both kind of  chill people so we got along really well  but he's not gonna be like hey let's  hang out um  and justin i also have that relationship  with justin i tend to hang out with  dudes more  um than i do with women uh  and i don't know if that's because like  i'd rather go out for a beer than like  get my nails done but um and that's very  um that's a total like  uh generalization